with Westworld canceled executive
producers Jonathan Nolan and Lisa Joy
have introduced another world that's
sure to be easy to understand with
nothing complicated whatsoever I am so
confused right now the peripheral based
off the 2014 book by the same name is a
Sci-Fi time traveling show that will
have you saying
thank you sir may I have another after
every episode we'll be going over
everything from stubs pulse peripherals
Neil prims the godfont timelines and
aunties so come along with me to the
year 2100 where London still looks like
crap and even the sex robots won't talk
to me the final episode of the season is
called the creation of a thousand
forests which is actually a quote from
Ralph Waldo Emerson which reads the
creation of a thousand forests is in one
Acorn this is in reference to
protagonist Flynn Fisher whose mother
sister father always called her their
Little Acorn because although an acorn
may be little it holds immense power
being able to turn into a Mighty Oak
Tree we don't know much about Flynn's
father although Flynn has fond memories
of him even using his Sim to replay
cherished Home Videos in a show where
infinite worlds are possible married
with the fact we've never seen her
father's face I wouldn't be surprised if
this character is somehow brought into
the show to really understand what's
going on we have to start Where it All
Began Flynn's brother Burton was chosen
by a secretive column company called
Milagros cold iron to test out a new
virtual reality headset this was due to
his impressive skills in a game called
Halcyon we actually see a little bit of
this game in the first episode when
Flynn takes on a bunch of Nazis but
little does this company know that it
wasn't actually Burton getting these
high scores but his sister Flynn so they
ship him this new headset and Burton
convinces his sister to take over for
him the better they do in the game the
more money they'll earn and with their
mother's health and decline in pain
medications sorely needed this is a
great opportunity for Flynn to rake in
some extra cash Flynn is teleported to a
futuristic London where the headset
makes her feel like she's really there
the big twist however is that this is
not a game at all but that she's
essentially piloting a robot in the
actual Future these robots are called
peripherals and are basically vessels
one can take over using this headset
they can be controlled by people in the
past or the present for example when
Flynn takes control of a peripheral
she's called a pult short for polter
guys because she is essentially a ghost
inhabiting this robotic body in this
future roughly 70 years from Flynn's
present Flynn is likely dead hence this
ghost-like analogy peripherals can also
be controlled by those in the present
for example Charice uses one to protect
herself from harm when she fights Flynn
the guards at the stub portals also use
peripherals allowing the locations of
such portals be simultaneously guarded
but their locations kept secret by
putting on the headset Flynn takes
control of a peripheral that looks like
her brother remember the company that
gave him the headset thought he was
going to be the one putting it on thus
they made him a peripheral to match but
as we'll soon find out this shell
company is actually run by a woman named
Alita West who's at the center of season
one story Elita has Flynn attend an
upscale party for a company called the
research institute it's one of three
major pillars that hold Society from the
brink of collapse after a series of
catastrophic events known as the jackpot
these are a collection of events that
resulted in the downfall of society and
they include things like the hacking of
the North American electrical grid
plagues environmental catastrophes and
even the launch of a nuclear bomb it is
said that over four decades seven
billion people were killed out of this
chaos emerged a mafia type organization
called the klept oligarchy they managed
to bring some stability to areas of the
world like London but to keep the klept
in check the second pillar emerged the
Metropolitan Police and the third pillar
is the research institute itself which
seeks to provide technical assistance to
society so that it can function and
Thrive Elita does not belong to any of
these pillars rather to a rogue group of
revolutionaries known as The neoprims
Who The kleps and others see as
terrorists their goal is to have London
burn and build something new from its
ashes but how can a group with almost no
power seek to overthrow a society that
controls everything that's where elita's
plan involving Flynn kicks in a year
before Elita disappears she meets up
with an ex-lover Dr Grace both of them
work for the research institute however
Grace in a far more secretive Department
Grace against all protocol shows Elita
the secret projects she's been working
on over the years one that allows the
research institute to alter events in
the past by altering the past they can
find ways to prevent future cataclysmic
events however as we'll find out Dr
Charisse Newland the head of the
research institute seems to have more
nefarious plans to try to make things as
easy to understand as possible we're
going to focus on two timelines first we
have what I like to call the future or
original timeline this is the one that
went through all those catastrophes and
got us to London in the year 2100. it's
in the future
where he is
2100. in this timeline technology was
created in the late 2080s that allowed
Humanity to access the past this isn't
your normal time travel like a Back to
the Future where the user himself is
teleported think of it more as a
transference of data than of a person
this transference also allows people
from the future to communicate with
those in the past via things like phones
and every time it changes made in the
past from someone in the future a stub
is created an alternate parallel
timeline or whirl think of it like a
branch forming from the trunk of a tree
a stub is created anytime A change is
made in the past allowing infinite stubs
to be created one such stub is Flynn's
in this original future timeline Flynn
went on to marry Sheriff Tommy
Constantine and have two children her
brother Burton was actually killed in
combat and their friend Connor didn't
lose an arm and legs what we see in this
show however is Flynn living one of
these alternate timelines or stubs in
this one Burton lives Conor loses most
of his limbs and Flynn never marries
Tommy so what happened here Elita learns
from grace hogart that the research
institute was secretly using stubs to
test out technology that could control
the chemistry in people's brains they
did this by setting up a shell company
in the past bidding on U.S military
contracts and installing haptic implants
in military personnel Burton and his
friends had these haptic implants
installed which resulted in the research
institute messing with these soldiers
compassion levels this is why Conor
risks his own life to save the Injured
Dog the one that will eventually get him
blown up the research institute messed
with the chemicals in his brain
theoretically if the research institute
could manipulate all of our brains into
being more compassionate it could end
violence as we know it this gets at why
Dr Charisse Newland has set up this
secret program in the first place as she
tells inspector Ainsley lobeer in
episode 7 most of the jackpot stuff that
happened was because of Humanity's
resistance to one human trait a
persistent self-destructive distance to
acting for a collective good in her mind
if we could make people more
compassionate we could avoid the very
tragedies that befell Us in the past the
research institute already has implants
in almost everybody so if word got out
that they were working on a program to
control people it would not be a good
look hence while she'll stop at nothing
to get control of Elita who has somehow
managed to steal this program's data
elita's plan was to have Burton seduce
Mariel Rafael a member of the research
institute's secret program have her eye
taken out and put into his body this way
they could access the retina scanner at
the godfont a device which allows the
user access to stubs and have this data
downloaded into Burton's haptic system
the only problem is it's not Burton
who's controlling the peripheral it's
Flynn who doesn't have a haptic system
thus the headset translated the data
into bacterial DNA which started to
colonize her brain don't ask me how this
works it's just one of those things the
show expects you to go along with this
is why Flynn has no idea idea why people
are after her they say she stole
something but she has no idea what she
stole and it's this Dad is overtaking of
her brain which gives her side effects
like that weird Hulk grip and sporadic
seizures this brings us to the final
episode where Ainsley lobeer finds
herself in a difficult predicament side
with Charisse or with Flynn as a senior
inspector of the Metropolitan Police she
has tremendous power and learned of
sharice's abuse of the stub Charisse
tried to convince her that everything
she was doing was for the common good
should the neoprims or the klept get a
hold of this stub which contains the
data to their mind control program
something they call a neural adjustment
mechanism it would be disastrous on the
other hand low beer could work with
Flynn this seems to be her choice at the
end of the season when she states that
they have work to do but her motivations
on why she chooses Flynn are vague Ash
one of Lev's hackers even says lobeer
has her own agenda all we learned from
low beer is that Flynn has the capacity
to work in her world in ways which are
Beyond her if if I were to take a guess
this has something to do with her
daughter Beatrice in episode 7 we
learned Beatrice is likely an AI based
off her own daughter in return for her
help Flynn wants a medication to help
her dying mother but when lobeer
consults the antes she's informed there
is nothing that can help her and they
give her 23 days to live the antes are
the Metropolitan police's data sorting
algorithm which can be used to store
information to make assumptions about
the future Ash tells Charisse that the
data she's been looking for this entire
season is stored in Flynn's brain Ash
who is working for charisse's Nemesis 11
zubov has switched sides after Lev slash
asean's face in exchange for this
information she wants Lev killed so
Charisse knows she must kill Flynn even
if it means destroying decades a worth
of research and she'll do this by
altering conditions in her stubs so that
the jackpot comes earlier specifically a
nuclear attack that could wipe out her
hometown later in the episode Tommy
asked Flynn if she knows anything about
a recent warning from the Department of
Homeland Security regarding a terrorist
threat to a nuclear missile silo near
where they live it seems as though
charisse's plan is well underway
meanwhile Flynn and wolf continue their
search for Elita eventually heading to
the place where wilf and Elita grew up
and called their secret place there he
finds a young robotic or peripheral
version of her the same one we saw at
the beginning of episode 1. it's
interesting to note that in the scene
from episode 1 her goal is to save the
world but not their world saving the
world my world is long past saving I
thought that was always your point I
didn't say our world she leads him to
the camp where they first met and talks
about how the ground underneath them are
filled with thousands of bodies he
doesn't even remember the death of his
mother sisters or brother because the
implant inside him also suppresses these
memories Elita took hers out and
memories came flooding back however
taking it out also means losing your
immunity boost to whatever seems to be
plaguing the world around them you may
have noticed these giant sculptures with
air turbines on them all we know is that
they're called air scrubbers and capture
carbon from the atmosphere so it appears
that global warming is but another
catastrophe included in the jackpot I
also like how these scrubbers are in the
form of classical sculptures which
symbolize order among chaos much like
classical painting and music brought
uniformity and order the implants that
suppress memories work in the favor of
the clip to massacred millions of
survivors for fear they were spreading
contagion by stopping these memories
that klept could prevent discontent and
potential Uprising nolita has assembled
a quote Army of the dispossessed but
they can't possibly take on the research
institute and cleft on their own the
secret to bringing them down lies in
Flynn's head I should also briefly
mention the setup for Jasper's takeover
of Corbell Pickett's narcotic operation
with korbel's seemingly on death's door
Jasper has to put up with getting
squeezed out of the operation so he puts
his drunk friends on a railroad but at
the last minute changes his mind
remember this is a guy whose wife said
he'd never heard a fly unfortunately
it's too late and before Jasper can
rescue them a train kills everyone in
the car this made me think of young
Jasper who grew up watching his uncle
corbel kill members of a motorcycle gang
in a heated car for as Korbel says you
won't get anywhere in life Jasper if you
don't have courage to be cruel man will
Jasper become this cruel person or will
his empathy give in we know empathy has
been a big theme of the series meanwhile
Flynn comes up with a radical plan to
stop Charisse from blowing up a nuclear
bomb near her hometown this plant
involves making Charice think that
Flynn's been killed here's where things
get buddy since the show doesn't really
give us straight answers but this is
what I think happens and you can let me
know in the comments if I'm way off base
first we know that low beer can create
new stubs and that Flynn wants to hide
in one if she could have that precious
data downloaded to her from the future
is it not possible she could have it
uploaded there this means it's entirely
possible Flynn could have that data
transferred to a version of herself in a
different stub more likely however is
that this new stub acts like a save
point in a video game in the original
stub she'll be killed by Conor but in
the new one she'll have this same data
instilled in her brain so if Conor did
actually kill her at the end it means
Flynn sacrificed herself so that
everyone in her world wouldn't be nuked
and that this new Flynn can carry on the
task of taking down Charice and the clap
now we actually never see her die we
just hear The Gunshot go off but let me
know what you guys think happened this
pocket watch is also confusing it seems
to act as some sort of key allowing the
creation of new stubs it certainly
sounds like she destroys this pocket
watch in the end but we know there are
always other ways into a stub the show
does not end there in a post-credit
scene Lev zubov who's supposed to be
attending an event with his father is
surprised to see other high members of
the klept in his place they want to cut
any affiliation with Flynn stubb and
kill anyone associated with it not just
that but quote the whole tree which
implies any and all stubs this means
Flynn's World which we thought would
have been saved is still in Jeopardy as
well as the new stub with the data in it
it also implies anyone involved with Lev
including wilf Ash and asean will need
to be killed as well if Lev doesn't
clean this up it's heavily implied his
wife and children will be killed my mind
is utterly scrambled from this show but
now I want to hear from you what did you
think of the peripheral season one and
what are your theories leave them in the
comments below thanks for watching
everyone make sure to like And subscribe
and for more bad takes you can follow me
on Twitter and Instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember I am so
confused right
foreign